فالرئيس السابق دونل ترامب لا يكاد يتنفس
سعداء حتى يتلقى ضربه جديده مره من
الديمقراطيين واخرى من المحاكم تليها اخرى
من مسؤول رفيع او حتى عضو في الكونجرس
فجديد القضيه ان ترامب متهم بالكذب على
وزاره العدل في قضيه الوثائق السريه وفقا
للمدعي العام وزير العدل السابق وليامبرغ
الذي اكد انه اخطا في فهم قانون السجلات
بار في حديثا لتلفزيون سي بي سي الامريكي
قال ان النظريه القانونيه التي يحصل من
خلال على خطط المعركه ومعلومات الامن
القومي الحساسه كانها اوراقه الشخصيه هي
نظريه سخيفه فالمدعي العام ووزير العدل
السابق وصف تصرفات ترامب في المنصوص عليها
في لائحه اتهام من 49 صفحه بانها ضاره ليس
فقط للبلاد ولكن ايضا لحزب الجمهوري
والحركه المحافظه التي يقودها ترامت نفسه
فالهجوم على ترامب طالب شخصيه شخصه بشكل
مباشر فبارع اعتبر الرئيس السابق بالنرجس
البارع الذي دائما وضع غروره قبل كل شيء
اخر وفق ما نقلت نيويورك تايمز بار صعد
الخطاب ضد ترامب اكثر فاكثر وقال بلدنا لا
يمكن ان يكون جلسه علاج لرجل مضطرب مثل
هذا على حد وصفه طبعا كان بار طبعا احد
اعضاء حكومه ترامب قبل ان يبتعد عنه بعد
احداث الكافه السادس من يناير 20 21
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات